or we can turn back to northern ireland
now as we expect the government to tell
us what it wants to change about the
protocol that has created this trade
border in the rsc xinfane recently made
history by winning the most votes and
seats in the election but it's been
unable to take its place in the assembly
as the dep refuses to take part until
the protocol is reformed
or scrapped or we can go live to dublin
now we can speak to you at the chinfane
president mary lou mcdonald
now as we just heard from branson lewis
the uk government's going to be
publishing legislation tomorrow that we
believe could override parts or change
parts of the protocol in northern
ireland
you told my colleague beth rigby that
the blizzard of paper is problematic so
do you have sympathy with the view that
the northern ireland protocol does need
to be changed
no i do not and i have even less
sympathy with a tory government that
brags now for such a long time that it
intends to breach international law
we're we're just about i think 40 days
out now from that election in in the
north
and we don't have institutions of
government it's it's utterly disgraceful
that we're in this place and bear in
mind a majority a significant majority
of people return to the assembly in the
north of ireland support the protocol
the protocol is working the protocol is
the mechanism that gives the north
uniquely unfettered access to the
european market and that is why we see
in the north of ireland in contrast with
britain with the exception of the the
city of london the the economy is strong
the economy is growing and what the tory
government is proposing to do in
breaching international
law is to create huge huge damage to the
northern economy to the irish economy
they propose to breach international law
and they are on an agenda of undermining
attacking and damaging the good friday
agreement
you say that a couple of things to
unpack there you say that the
tory government the uk government
is going to breach international law now
brandon lewis told me on the program he
assured me several times that the
changes would not
break international law
what evidence do you have that it will
well can i can i well can i say to you
that brandon lewis is talking through
his hat and not for the first time
brandon lewis should know the tory
government
should know that where there are issues
to be resolved with the protocol
issues of smoothing out its application
there are mechanisms through which that
can happen there is a willingness there
is a willingness to engage by the
european commission but the british
government has refused to engage
has not been constructive has sought a
destructive path and is now proposing to
introduce legislation that will
undoubtedly breach international law and
by the way against the expressed
democratic wishes of people in the north
of ireland who went to the polls and who
made their democratic decision and have
returned a majority of members that
support the protocol all of the business
organizations across the north of
ireland will tell you that yes there are
issues that need to be resolved get that
done get that done by way of negotiation
but they will also tell you that the
protocol is necessary
that the protocol is working that the
protocol can work better because all of
them be very very clear no the jobs
prosperity and healthy economic growth
rely on access to the european market
nobody wants to jeopardize and forego
that and it's astonishing
that the british government brags
consistently that they will
change as they put it or ditch elements
of the protocol breach international law
bring themselves into a collision with
europe at a time when we have your uh
war in europe cause untold economic
damage to the north of ireland and why
why well because there is an internal
leadership problem within the tory party
it is disgraceful to use the north of
ireland to use ireland as a bargaining
chip
in their ongoing collision with europe
all designed to boost the ego at the
leadership ambitions of either boris
johnson or one of his would-be
successors it's dishonorable stuff
by any measure extraordinary stuff
that the british parliament it seems now
is set to have tabled before it
legislation specifically designed to
breach an international agreement that
that very parliament ratified
and an agreement that not so long ago
the current occupant of number 10
downing street just described as oven
ready and let me emphasize again uh in
the democratic test on these matters at
the people of the north have spoken
a majority of mlas elected to the
assembly support the protocol and when
there is a vote in 2024 assuming that
the assembly is up and running and even
if it's not a majority of those mlas
will vote to continue and support that
protocol
and in 2024 of course according to the
brexit deal politicians in northern
ireland specifically get to decide
whether or not they want to keep the
protocol in place it's effectively like
an exit clause that was worked into the
original deal
i just wonder how important you think it
is that those politicians in northern
ireland get to make the final decision
on the protocol because you know there
is
rumors uh that the
uh that the
bills tomorrow the legislation
introduced tomorrow could effectively
override that concept vote
well let me say this uh just remember
that when when brexit happened and the
vote was taken people in the north voted
to remain just just remember that
and people on on a cross community basis
from from all walks of life voted to
remain and i would wager if there was a
vote on the brexit question again next
week or next month that by an even
greater margin people in the north of
ireland would vote uh to remain so
brexit never had the democratic consent
or imprimatur of the people of the north
and therefore any idea that uh the tory
government would try to rob the elected
representatives of the north of ireland
of their rightful decision
on this matter would be absolutely
outrageous and and would mean that not
alone is the tory government uh
waging an onslaught against the protocol
prepared to breach international law and
walk away from its international
obligations but that in fact it is uh
damaging undermining power sharing in
the north of ireland and it would be
further and very very
very very dangerous evidence of a tory
attack on the good friday agreement uh
itself a very very dangerous suggestion
i mean i i should say at this point
obviously that brandon lewis says that
part of the reason they want to do this
is to effectively restore all elements
of the good friday uh agreement as the
uh assemblies
listen sophie sophie
sophia that just needs to be scotched
i mean that that's just that's frankly
beyond disingenuous
uh the tory government consistently uh
abuses language uh in in a way that is
mesmerizing they say they want to
protect the good friday agreement when
they take the very actions that
undermine and that could potentially
destroy the good friday agreement that's
the reality and they are doing this in
plain sight they're colluding with the
section of political unionism to keep
the executive down in belfast to ensure
that the north-south element of the good
friday agreement is now
not operating to wage an attack on the
protocol the protocol to guarantee
access to the european market but
crucially to ensure no hardening of the
border on on ireland they have acted
unilaterally
in terms of legislation to deal with
victims and survivors of the conflict
they threatened still to withdraw from
the european convention and human rights
all of the building blocks in other
words upon which the good friday
agreement has been carefully constructed
by all of us are now being openly
attacked and undermined by the tory
government and i think it is so
important that everybody in political
life quite irrespective of their view be
they conservative
be they labor wherever we fall on the
political spectrum we have a joint
vested interest in ensuring that the
good friday agreement is protected and
the tories need to be called out on this
not just by politics but by every sector
across civic society and ultimately by
by the people and i have whereas i have
no confidence i have to tell you in
boris johnson or his government i have
every confidence in decent people across
britain to realize that jeopardizing the
good friday event and the peace that all
of us
have built is totally unacceptable
it's pretty clear how
strong you feel about this and would you
like to see the united states
potentially getting involved
the united states is involved the united
states is involved because they know as
surely as we know that what is at play
here is a very very deliberate set of
actions that undermine the good friday
agreement and everybody from from the
white house from president biden
across american politics on a bipartisan
basis and you know as well as i do there
are few issues that unite political
opinion in the united states but this is
one of them
all of us have skin in this game
everybody knows that to protect the good
friday agreement there is an absolute
imperative on boris johnson and his
government to act in good faith to act
constructively to engage to respect
the rule of law and to understand that
ireland will not be will not be let me
repeat the collateral damage in the
games and gamesmanship at play currently
within the tory party and i have to tell
you i believe that not alone
do we have international diplomatic and
political opinion on the side of ireland
on this question i think any person with
an ounce of common sense and an ounce of
decency and the people of britain have
that in abundance know that all of us
have to get on with our lives we're
living through a cost of living crisis
it's going to get really hard in the
autumn and the winter all of us know
that we need a level of stability
maturity and competence and all of us
know
that our relationships with each other
are fundamentally rooted in the good
friday agreement and the protection of
that we are at time but i do want to
talk to you just very finally about the
prospect of a border pole uh essentially
a referendum on a united island you've
said previously that you think that will
take place within the next 10 years and
you said that you want to see an
indication from the british government
as to how they might measure when they
would regard it to be
appropriate
obviously in scotland it was when the s
p had it in their manifesto they then
went on to
win uh the most seats uh in the election
and went on to enact that referendum so
at what trigger point would you like to
see
a border pole being called in ireland
in northern ireland sorry well my
priority at
at this point well there will have to be
two referendums in fact sophie in the
north and in the south in both
jurisdictions
at this point the the big priority for
me and for us is that preparation for
such a referendum is underway we have to
have a very wide all of society
conversation and that has to include
unionism those for who will campaign
against a reunification those for whom
as we move into united ireland this
would not be their first preference but
we need
we need to uh hear all of those uh
voices and so i have urged dublin to
begin the preparation now i think there
is uh nothing to be gained by burying
our heads in the sand i mean the recent
election in the north is just the latest
demonstration of of how profound the
change is uh across ireland and of
course the government at westminster the
the british government i think have to
indicate what their view is how how they
view the matter of at the tipping point
when the referendums will be held but
either either or whatever the answer
might be to that particular question be
in no doubt the change a positive change
exciting change progressive change is
underway in ireland that's good news for
all of us and this island it's good news
also for britain and because
part of the whole project of building a
new island is building renewing
consolidating that relationship that we
have with our nearest neighbor
okay uh thank you very much for coming
on the program uh this morning very
strong views are given from yourself of
course and thank you very much